et ce soir un jour avec la chasse tant
les chasseurs ont encore quinze jours
pour s'adonner à leur passion la chasse
est ouverte jusqu'au 15 avril prochain
ils sont environ 800 à la réunion des
passionnés c'est avec un petit groupe de
passionnés justement d'amis chasseurs à
la plaine des cafres à que jean marc
collienne et laurent fignon sont allés à
la poursuite des petits rongeurs alors
en six heures plaine des cafres 23e km
le jour est à peine levé clôture pain
emmène sa chienne préféré à la chasse
aux temps qu il n'y a pas le loot d'arc
où seul nom les meilleurs prix l'idée
assez troqué à savoir pour nous
retrouverons là haut c'est le lieu dit
quoi tranquille et c'est toujours la
même petite bande
claude jean félix jacky et frédéric
sarre au coude à coude
le second chien lui s'appelle malbar la
cause n'est pas une cloche ben en fait
ce matin je me pense que les chasse
l'autre donc j'ai pas trop envie avant
tout le monde et combien
ben pas si je dois faire quoi nous mange
seul bon sens vous voyez plus nous
laisse de chien mandat fort et des
causes nationales yunus est là mais il
faut laisser le chien ou île et le trou
[Musique]
pendant plusieurs minutes les hommes et
les chiens se relaie pour fouiller
quand tout à coup jean-félix enfonce son
sabre bâton bouge pas voilà tout le
temps je fais parfois très profond mais
bon là ça les a alors placé passion
depuis les petits les pumas mais les
passionnés pour achat web la chasse même
les bleus car il sait aussi non
seulement elle me ment pas tant qu non
comme une âme en partant il est bizarre
parce que je dis aux abords de chasse et
mentalement
ah la la
à la main
[Musique]
là
la vie
anna hazare
[Musique]
il fait mentir oui et comment j'étais
mordu commencera pas disparaître pendu à
abaisser ce sens comme savent le faire
les papas mandat peut être dangereux
comme ça là là comme ça donc elle peut
aussi encore la définit comme ça la
pousse comme ça tout à fait pas trop
foot anglais oui mais en amont pied se
lève tard ce soit lâché mi-août ramallah
alors quelle sensation bombe à bagdad le
gars juste sous fidèle à cette fois les
chiens ont filé et les chasseurs sont
arrivés trop tard chez accueil c'est le
chèque la trappe et là ils doivent
s'attendre il à crocs pousse à tout le
corps et la picarde s'est caché dans les
racines la chance oui bah oui
et juste au moment où il s'apprêtait à
abandonner la partie le voilà il est
sorti
et ap combien d'enfants du 4 6 8 6
oh la la
[Musique]
et que ça aurait pu en bord de lentilles
chasseurs c'est notre tradition depuis
longtemps mené la danse de parents les
parents à suivre
après tout comme les plaines du temps
les nazis mais dans mon jardin foulée ce
que vous direz vous
c'est ce que tu es dans la paix à mon
avis elle a vendu des temps la
corrélation des temps que détruit
beaucoup les quatre ballons et affirment
qu'ils chassent seulement pour le
plaisir en respectant la réglementation
au début de la saison il leur est arrivé
de ramener jusqu'à 67 tang
cette fois la dizaine de team usa fera
juste un bon cari
[Musique]